>> TONIGHT PRESIDENT TRUMP
UNVEILS FAKE NEWS AWARDS.
MICHELLE INVESTIGATES ON CRTV
AND THE HILL JOE CONCHA I
LOVED EVERY ONE OF IT NEVER
MIND THE STORIES THEY DON’T
COVER.
THIS IS TIP OF THE SPHERE THE
TICHT ICEBERG, MICHELLE.
>> IT IS, IT’S SIMPLY
BRILLIANT I HAVE TO HAND IT TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP, AND TO
EVERYONE WHO COMPILED THIS
LIST.
I THINK THAT THE EXECUTION
LEADING UP TO THE REVELATION
OF THESE AWARDS WAS ALSO
BRILLIANT.
LOOK AT WHAT YOU HAD.
YOU HAD ALL OF THESE THUMB
SUCKERS IN THE MEDIA WORKING
THEMSELVES UP INTO OLYMPIC
SIZE LATHER.
I COUNTED HALF A DOZEN PIECES
JUST OVER THE LAST 24 HOURS DE
CRYING FAKE NEWS AWARDS BEFORE
THEY WERE EVEN GIVEN AS SOME
SORT OF ESCALATION AND THREAT
OF VIOLENCE AGAINST PRESS
FREEDOMS.
AND, OF COURSE, WE HAD JEFF
SNOW FLAKE OR CORN FLAKE,
FLAKE, FLAKE,
>> FROSTEE FLAKE.
>> FROSTEE FLAKE, ON THE
SENATE FLOOR EMBARASSING
HIMSELF WITH HYPERBOLIC SPEECH
COMPARING OUR PRESIDENT IN A
FUN WAY BEING ABLE TOY TELL
TROOPS ABOUT THE FAKE MEDIA
COMPARING OUR PRESIDENT TO
STALIN.
THESE PEOPLE AS YOU SO DEATHLY
POINTED OUT OVER THE LAST
HOURS AND DAYS AND MONTHS,
HAVE COMPLETELY LOST THEIR
MIND.
AND NOW PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
GOING TO FORCE THEM TO COVER
EACH AND EVERY SINGLE ITEM ON
THE LIST.
>> EVERYBODY IN THE BUBBLE.
ECHO CHAMBER.
YOU KNOW WHO THEY ARE.
WE CAN NAME -- WE DO NAMEWE CANE
THEM.
THIS IS WHY IT’S SO IMPORTANT.
THEY’VE BEEN SAYING THIS IS SO
BAD FOR FREEDOM OF THE PRESS.
YOU KNOW WHAT’S BAD FOR
FREEDOM OF THE PRESS, LYING.
AND DOING AND NOT ONLY LYING,
BUT CHOICES, THEY WON’T COVER
THE BIGGEST STORIES THAT EXIST
IN OUR LIFETIME.
AND BECAUSE OF THEIR AGENDA
AND THEY STILL CAN’T GET OVER
THEY WERE WRONG ON THE
ELECTION.
>> OR SHAWN YOU CAN MAKE THE
ARGUMENT THAT DONALD TRUMP IS
EXERCISING HIS FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHT BY PUSHING BACK AT MEDIA
AS HE DID --
>> WAIT HE HAS ONE?
>> PRESIDENTS HAVE REALLY
NEVER DONE THAT.
REPUBLICANS ARE WORRIED THEY
GET BAD PRESS SO THEY DIDN’T
PUNCH BACK LIKE THIS I WOULD
ARGUE TRUMP SUPPORTERS
PROBABLY SEE THE MEDIA AS
OPPOSITION PARTY MORE THAN
PELOSI OR BOOKER OR WAR.
>> WHY SHOULDN’T HE PUSH BACK.
>> I’M NOT SAYING HE
SHOULDN’T.
>> THIS IS WELL-DESERVE ADD
WARDS FOR LOSERS.
>> IF YOU SAY THE LIST IT’S
MICRO HE KAX OF 2016, QUICK
CNN WON FOUR AWARDS AND
THEY’LL MAKE AN AD CAMPAIGN
OUT OF THAT.
I’M NOT BEING SARCASTIC
THEY’LL SEE IT AS A BATH THEY’LF
HONOR.
>> AND I BELIEVE THEY SAID IT
165 TIMES.
>> I WANT TO SAY IT HERE BUT I
CAN’TFY SAY IT HERE I HAVE TO
SIT IN A MEETING ABOUT POLICY.
I’LL LET MICHELLE JUMP IN
AGAIN.
"NEW YORK TIMES" TWO, ABC ONE
NEWS WEEK ONE.
BUZZ FEED, THEY RELOOSEED
DOSSIER WAS NOT NOMINATED
INTERESTING.
UNSCATHED.
NETWORKS THAT DIDN’T GETNETWORKT
AWARD, NBC, SURPRISEAWARD, NBC,S
AND FOX NEWS.
SHOCKING.
>> AND WHAT’S HAPPENING I
THINK IF YOU LOOK AT
STATISTICS I SHOWED LAST
NIGHT.
2017, THE YEAR THEY TRIED TO
DESTROY A PRESIDENT WITH MEDIA
RESEARCH.
BUT IT’S ALSO A YEAR THAT THEY
CREATED THE BIGGEST DISSERVICE
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THEY ALL HURT WHEN THEY CANNOT
GET THE TRUTH, MICHELLE.
>> THAT’S RIGHT.
AND JUST TO ADD A FOOTNOTE TO
JOE’S TALLY, THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" I THINK I WOULD
ACTUALLY ADD ONE MORE SINCE,
OF COURSE, ERIC LICKBLAUGH
CAME FROM CNN TO COMMIT THE
SAME KIND OF MEDIA MALPRACTICE
HE DID AT THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
FISH WRAP OF RECORD.
AND LOOK TO THE POINT THAT YOU
MADE, SHAWN, TOO, ABOUT WHY
SHOULDN’T OUR PRESIDENT PUSH
BACK AGAINST THE MEDIA?
I WOULD TURN THAT BACK, TOO,
AGAINST ALL THOSE REPUBLICAN
SENATOR IS SELLOUTS OVER THE
LAST COUPLE OF DAYS, WHO HAVE
BEEN AUDITIONING FOR JOBS WITH
LIBERAL MEDIA.
DO THEY NOT REMEMBER THE PUSH
BACK UNDER THE BUSH -- OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
AND I’M NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
ALL THE SPYING THE OBAMA
JOURNALISTS FROM JOURNALISTS FRL
ATKINSON TO ASSOCIATED FROS
FOX NEWS.
REMEMBER OBAMA WHITE HOUSE HAD
SPECIFICALLY ASSIGNED THE
WHITE HOUSE COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR AT THE TIME ANITA
DUNN TO GO OUT EVERY DAY AT
PRESS BRIEFINGS AND
SPECIFICALLY ATTACK FOX NEWS.
AND WHAT DO THESE PEOPLE WANT
TO DO, DISARMOUR PRESIDENT AND
HIS SUPPORTERS AND GRASSROOTS
CONSERVATIVES AND INDEPENDENT
ENTERS THAT PUT HIM IN OFFICE
AND GAG HIM FROM USING HIS OWN
FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHT TO PUSH
BACK WHERE THE MEDIA IS WRONG.
>> HE WILL NEVER, EVER BE THE
PERSON THEY WANT HIM TO BE.
HE WILL NEVER PUT CARGO PLANE
LOADS OF CASH AND GIVE THEM TO
MULLAS AND KISS THEIR [BLEEP]
AND TRY TO BRIBE THEM NOT TO
BE MURDERING DICTATORS TOBE MURO
WANT.
>> SAYING [BLEEP] WILL NOT
HAVE YOU SIT IN A MEETING
TOMORROW.
>> I WON’T GO TO THE MEETING.
>> PEOPLE SAY MAYBE THINGS
WILL CHANGE IN 2018 THEY
CLEARLY STHEEN YEAR HAS BEEN
WORSE THAN LAST YEAR.
ONLY 6 DAYS N WHAT HAPPENED
WITH SANJAY GUPTA HE DOES A
DIAGNOSIS FROM AFAR AND HE’S A
MUR OWE SURGEON.
THINK OF HIM AS ELECTRICIAN
AND RONNIE JACKSON WAS NOT THE
ONLY PERSON INVOLVED IN THE
CARDIOVASCULAR PART OF TRUMP’S
PROGNOSIS AND HE ALSO WAS
CONSULTING WITH CARDIOVASCULAR
SURGEONS FROM THE CLEVELAND
CLINIC ONE IN THE KUPTY AND
YOU HAVE AN ELECTRICIAN
TALKING ABOUT WHAT A PLUMBER
SHOULD BE DOING.
AND IT’S LIKE WHAT I GO TO GET
>> THANKS FOR SHARE>> THANKS FO.
>> LIKE MY DAD HAD I HAVE TO
GO EVERY FOUR YEARS CALL THE
PODIATRIST.
>> YOU DON’T WANT TO SAY THAT
ON CNN THE [BLEEP] HOLE
NETWORK.
>> WE HAVE TO ROLL.
>> I WAS TRYING TO MAKE A
POINT.
>> PRESIDENT HAS A GREAT SENSE